what's shape I've just evaluated the
derivative if - okay so I'm gonna pop
that on and I've got two graphs here
I'd like you to sketch these Cartesian
planes beneath each other because we're
going to do some comparisons with them
it's a very very simple graph right but
there are some great things that you can
notice about it for instance when you
think about your original x squared
parabola right let's think about its
gradient okay and this is actually
something I'm gonna encourage you to put
onto the diagram itself over here on the
left hand side the gradient all the way
from negative infinity up until zero
except the zero the gradient along here
is negative
these are minus signs okay it's a
decreasing function for X is less than
zero right and when you have a look at
this you can see that this negative is
matched by the fact that the derivative
is negative for X is less than zero
right and in fact the further away you
go toward infinity the more negative it
becomes what does that correspond to
geometrically what is that what does
that mean up here yeah it's well it's
super super negative that's really
really steep right which is why if you
draw this further it sort of seems like
it's going vertical it doesn't it but it
seems like it more negative down here
means steeper up here okay steeper no
naked direction as you approach on the
derivative as you get closer encroaches
zero the derivative is approaching zero
right what does a derivative or should I
say our gradient of zero what does that
mean yeah it's not rising at all right
this is the greater the tangent right
the tangent along here is already on the
diagram it's the x-axis it's horizontal
right a grade of zero means rather than
dropping like a rock right I'm slowing
down and then here I um I stopped I
if you want to think about this in terms
of movement it's like I'm dropping down
really fast over here as you'll see in a
second I'm increasing very fast over
here but right there I stop which is why
this point here is called a stationary
point not stationary with an e which is
like whoo I have really fancy stationery
that I got in typo
I mean stationary with an A which means
it describes a point where there is no
movement right it is not going up it's
not going down it's stationary okay but
not only is it a stationary point after
that point the gradient is positive
let's secure my plus signs indicating
that's an increasing function you might
have seen some of this like diagrams or
than your textbooks in that container
right and what it corresponds to of
course is that my derivative is positive
derivative is positive if X is greater
than zero which means it's increasing
and the further you go in this direction
Tommy when is this derivative when is it
going to stop getting bigger never it
never stopped it just keeps on going and
going and going which corresponds to
geometrically this is going to get
steeper and steeper forever right
forever that's a bit weird we can't do
that in real life Franklin you can't
imagine a mountain that gets steeper and
steeper forever eventually it stops by
or it's it just levels out and becomes a
cliff or whatever okay but this
literally gets steeper steeper forever
there's no point you can say up can't go
past there anymore it'll just keep going
now because it transitions from going
down to going up this point here the
origin is not only a stationary point
where it stops this is a word I
introduced before a phrase it's also a
turning point because the graph is
coming now and then it turns around and
goes up obviously you can imagine a
turning point that's upside-down there
could go up and then go down if I just
slapped a minus sign on the front of
this thing okay so it is both a
stationary point and a turning point but
these two things are kind of like
rectangles and squares rectangles with
all squares are rectangles
right all squares are rectangles but not
all rectangles or squares so in order to
turn in order to tell you have to stop
don't you write like you can't turn
around without stopping but once you
stop you don't have to turn you don't
have to turn so for instance here am i
walking across the room and then I stop
and I'm not going to turn now I'm just
going to keep going right so there was a
stationary point in it but there was no
turning point I didn't go back and face
the opposite direction okay think think
of a graph you almost just recently drew
one did you know you didn't yet oh you
may get it but you did a graph that
stops its increasing increase increasing
its thoughts and that just says yeah I'm
just gonna keep it right the first time
okay which graph is the most obvious one
yeah the cubic curve right the cubic
curve if you just think of the vanilla y
equals executes it does this it goes
stop and then it just keeps going
there's no turn stationary point not
anyway we'll have will develop more
language to describe this point later on
but that's enough for now yeah
okay great yes sir it's like I couldn't
have done this I couldn't plan is better
on planted okay so next a little bit of
notation okay it's not really new pace
but it's new in this context right
remember in function notation if I say
if I say I'm gonna go F of one what that
means is you take your function right
and you say well okay that's one squared
that's one what is this number
what is that it corresponds to a
coordinate right this x equals this this
input is my x coordinate right and this
output is my y coordinate agree okay but
in exactly the same way that has this
notation I have this right so if I say
now F - one right
this doesn't mean how high are you when
x equals one this means what is your
gradient at x equals one and it's two
times 1 which is 2 okay what does that
correspond to
well at this point what's the gradient
of the tangent that's their attentions
going off like that ok my scale is not
fantastic but that's increasing it'll be
2x right I guess it would be a bit steep
up really ok but my scale I haven't any
put on it ok now this means right so
like I said you might like to put that
on that's the y coordinate there F and F
dash will give me the gradient at that
particular point so this is the gradient
function this is what happens the
gradient function and that spot at x
equals 1 now if you consider well let's
just chuck in some other values right
well let's think about F equals negative
1 on the opposite side right because
it's what kind of symmetry does this
function have it's an even function so
unsurprisingly you're going to get the
same y-coordinate so you're at
- one one okay but when you pop it f -
when you pop it - 1 into F - you're
getting 2 times negative 1 which of
course is minus - what does that mean
okay yeah you've got you've got a
tangent there right which has the exact
opposite gradient of this in fact by the
way see how this function here is even
this function has symmetry - doesn't it
hmm wonder why that is
odd why is that we'll have a look at
that a bit later